Okay, welcome, everybody. It's Dr. Kevin Cutters. Today, we're going to go over some topical cancer quarter killers, some things to do with skin cancers, topical cancers that might be beneficial for you, because as we all age, we end up with some skin lesions that many times the dermatologist, they want to excise and remove.
And there may be another way to deal with it before we want to go that route. So let's talk about them. So mainly we're talking about three main skin cancers. There's others. My cancer is different.
Cancer was so rare. We're not going to talk about it. When you look up skin cancer, you won't even see it. So basal cell carcinoma is the one that's most common. This first one here.
And it basically looks, this is pretty much how much it looks like with most people. You see that a lot of people's face and head can be in other parts of the body, but it's very common as we age.
And though this can be a deadly cancer as well, it's probably one of the easier ones to treat, topically, and we'll go over that.
Squamous cell carcinoma is a little bit harder to distinguish. It looks similar to basal cell, but it tends not to have that shiny appearance to it.
Squamous cell can be can go metastatic and become deadly as well. It's not quite as common as basal cell melanoma is not as common again, but it is, it is much more deadly. And this is a, this is a real,
and we call it blatant example of melanoma in this picture. I have never seen a melanoma look quite as angry as that. I think another picture coming up, it looks more like this.
Then it does look like that other picture, where it obviously looks like something's like very ominous.
So it's hard to distinguish melanoma from a mole often, and that's why people will often get scared. Usually you can tell the difference because, oh, I have never seen this before.
This is new than you are concerned that it is a melanoma.
Basal cell and squamous look quite a bit different than melanoma, melanomas are the darker color. So it's pretty easy, pretty easy to tell the difference between those type of tumors.
So causes, when we talk about causes of cancer, usually you're going to see on the television that the cause of skin cancer is the sun.
Well, the sun is not the cause of cancer. So let's just clear that up.
However, getting burned can cause cancer. So what can cause skin cancer is damage to cells.
So if you damage the cells, it's like any other cancer. If I have liver cancer, why did I get liver cancer? Because something got into the cell to damage the cell and to disrupt that DNA replication of the cell.
Well, same thing with skin cancer, something damages the cell. If you're going out in the sun and getting burned on a regular basis, you do have an increase risk of skin cancer.
So do people in Florida and in Southern California, in Mexico, have an increased risk of skin cancer. Only if they're getting burned on a regular basis, I would say that a person from the north who was not used to be in the sun and goes out of the sun, it gets burned.
It has an increased risk of skin cancer much more than somebody who lives in a southern area. It is used to getting sun. It is not getting burned. They might have a real healthy tan, but they're not getting burned.
So many things you'll see in the news is that you need to wear sunblock because that the sun is this awful evil thing that is causing skin cancer.
Well, the chemicals in most of the over the counter sunblock are probably bigger cancer killers than the sun is. Now, I don't believe that you should not use sunblock and just go get burned. You have to be careful with that.
Basically, I don't ever wear sunblock when I have type of skin. I tend not to burn very easy. If I'm careful, I wear a shirt or a hat. And I'll just tan. So I don't worry about getting burned as much as some other people, people with some region type skin.
It's not going to be burned really easy and using a natural sunblock is what we recommend, something without all those chemicals that is not good for you either.
So it's damaged to the cell, that is really the cause of skin cancer. And the most common damage to the cell is a frequent burning.
So you can get burns from other reasons too. That's why in person does radiation for breast cancer, very, very common that they end up with melanoma years later in that spot that they had radiation because the radiation caused the skin damage similar to getting burned in the sun.
What are some things you can do for it? So we're going to go mildest to strongest here on some of the topical things that you can do for skin cancers essential oils is probably the mildest things, the easiest things to do.
Essential oils are available just about anywhere these days and using a drop of tea tree oil or oregano or fragrance sensor burr and you can try a whole bunch of different kinds of different types of essential oils that are out there are based upon what they're distilling this off of
to get the essential oil that's hence the name of the essential oil and they all have little bit different properties, but it's the terpenes that are in the essential oil that really can be effective for cancer.
So there's there's at least a dozen other ones that are, you know, have a lot of research on cancer that you could use.
I just picked three here for this topic, but these would typically be used more so on the basil cell squamous cell type cancers.
I have not seen essential oils be successful for melanoma personally, but certainly for basil cell we've had patients use tea tree oil or oregano oil on their basil cell and it killed the basil cell and it flaked off.
And it was gone a numerous occasions so this is the easiest thing to do because it is clear it is painless it is it is simple to do to drop on your finger, dab it out that spot on your cheek or wherever that spot is nobody knows the difference and you do that carry that bottle around in your pocket, do that three four or five six times a day every time you remember it.
And you could have good success with that I've actually used tea tree oil on a work that I wasn't sure that if it was a skin cancer basil cell, I still don't know up to this point could have been a basil cell could have been a squamous cell but within about a week it just flaked right off and was gone that I was dealing with that for probably about six months.
I was quite sure that it wasn't a melanoma so I just did the oil and I think I actually used the pan away oil that's a that other anti inflammatory oil by young maybe that's the oil that I used I just had it at home and I used that.
What we typically use for basil cell cancer is our curcuit cream that I developed it is a shade butter cream with curcuit in it and we use a little bit of blood work very small amount of.
black salve in it as well but it's just a tea little bit that you really wouldn't get a black salve reaction for it it's just the blood root of the black salve that we put in it and it's mainly curcumin the negative we've had a really really good success with this with basil cell and some squamous cell cancers the negative is that.
Curcumin is that yellow color and because of the yellow color it stays so you'll get a yellow spot if you thought your face it's not you know you got that yellow spot on your face and if you're putting it on at night and then you're going to bed it can stay your pillows so it's going to stay your pillow case it's going to stay your sheets it's going to stay anything that it gets in contact with so that's the negative.
Any topical curcuit cream the benefit is it's worked just about every patient we've used it on for basil cell for sure so it's been a nice good topical cream it's also great cream for arthritis and things like that so we use it for a few other things but that's our curcuit cream that we use this is only available to our patients because it's not labeled for sale.
Next thing is cure a germ that's a product that you can buy over the counter and it is it's a product that I don't have any testimonies because I've never used it and I haven't had any patients use it but I do know some other doctor friends of mine have used it with their patients.
And have used it quite well it gets it's something that you would use typically for the basil cell and squamous cell I have not heard any reports of it be helping with melanoma but this is a product that you could buy even an Amazon it's a it's a
I forgot what it's made of but it's got some really good curative properties in there for skin issues and it can be for you could use any of these that we've already mentioned you could use on moles you could use on warts there's benefits to any use of any of these products on the skin and such as well.
You could use do the same thing with this next one this is the CBD oil and cream.
This is from can away the case have we sell the most of this the involve just came up with a new one that we haven't we're just starting to carry right now called their ease product using a CBD cream or oil can be beneficial for any skin issues.
I don't have a lot of testimonials for topical cancers for this but we've had patients do it where they've had done this over their breast cancer over a cancer area that is it wasn't a skin cancer with some good success stories of that as well.
But certainly using a CBD cream over a cancer would be something to consider for sure it really has no side effects don't drawbacks it's clear it's similar to using essential oil in the fact that you're not going to state anything so you don't have that.
Secondary issues other things are using a poultice and I just put a picture of one of our videos Michelle and I did a member minute on poultices you can search that in our video archive.
That is something we've done a numerous patients is doing poultices and this isn't just over skin cancers this is over for anything of the skin or in a liver or over the breast.
But poultices tend to draw things out and that could be beneficial as well under the other category I also put THC which would be Rick Simpson's oil.
You know that may or may not be legal in your state so we'll talk a lot about that but that is something to consider as well Rick Simpson oil as high THC so that's the opposite component of the CBD that's found in marijuana and the THC could have excellent carried effects and that would be something that would be possible to even use over a melanoma as well.
And then the last one that we talk about is black sap again Michelle and I did a members minute on black sap itself giving you the pros and cons of black sap the biggest con of black sap is you do not want to do this on your own.
And without the following some doctors help and getting that head hold it going through it because it can be horribly painful as it draws out the cancer but we've seen this first hand with oh I don't know maybe it doesn't melanoma patients my wife beat one of them she had two spots of melanoma drawn out with the black sap took about 30 days for each spot to come out.
Extremely painful needed to get some payments for it and but it killed the melanoma that was six years ago now so she's got a clean bill of health as far as that goes so that's very good news and the first person we actually ever did this on was I don't know 10 years ago.
And I was looking up I had pictures because it took seven days for his to come out had pictures of it on my old computer, but I could take them out to show on the slide presentation, but it's pretty cool.
But black sap can be a ginormous life saver.
Again, I'm not a fan of getting cut on when you have skin cancer because it can tend to spread the circulated tumor cells everywhere through the body so that's not a big fan of that.
So if you could do things topically, I think you're much better off doing it topically or at least tempting to topically prior to doing any surgical intervention.
Now the problem is is that you go well how do I know if it's cancer or not what if this is just a mole and I'm going to put CBD oil on it or I'm going to put essential oils on.
There's nothing wrong with doing that you're not going to hurt yourself putting curcumin cream on a squit on something that looks like a squabic cell, but it's just a mole or it's just an injury or you got bit by a spider or you didn't even know it.
So using, you know, products like essential oils or curcumin cream or corridor or the, the, the sap is not going to be harmful for you so it's there's no harm, no foul in trying these things before you go and do a surgical intervention.
So somebody asked a question is the CBD oil clear yes it's a it's like a fascinating kind of looking substance, but it's fairly clear but it's more of a sap so it's not ready which is kind of nice so it will stay in place a little bit easier.
When we had patients put like a bandaid over that spot if so they're not wipe it off and it makes it easier, but if you're doing essential oils you don't necessarily want to put a bandaid on it because you want to keep dabbing it, it sure of the day and that's the better way to do it.
Again, you certainly would not do blackstab unless you had somebody supporting you, you were dealing with a practitioner, we were struck to you to do that.
I would we do not sell blackstab in our store for that reason we do not want any non patients find blackstab and try it themselves because I can have some scary scary side effects, but you could search easily on Google and find wonderful stories of people who use blackstab.
Here's a story of Bill O'Leary if you just search I just quickly search blackstab stories, his story came up on how he was successfully treated a melanoma on his nose with blackstab.
It doesn't show you the between here I'm sure he went through.
A month or two or six of healing for his nose to be perfectly healed over like that, but it's certainly a lot better than the alternative because the alternative on a cancer like this if you go in and they find out it's melanoma they're literally going to maybe do a biopsy of it here, take a little piece of that melanoma if you can see my cursor.
But then if it comes back positive then they're going to do what's called most surgery which is going to excise everything that they perfect that they can see visually and then they're going to send it to the lab right there while they have you still on the table.
See if the quote-unquote margins are clean and if the margins are not clean they're going to go deeper and deeper deeper.
For instance, on my wife's melanoma it was the size smaller that it died when we put the blackstab out there and it opened it up to about the size of a hard boiled egg.
So literally I believe if we did if we went in for the surgery should probably what I had her clavicle removed and had a very little function of a right arm at this point in time.
So it was much better going the route that we did in her recovery was so much nicer so.
But you can see stories like this online you can go on YouTube and get some stories as well.
Now you'll hear the medical reports from the medical community and those that they've hired to try to destroy this type of treatment.
Say also it's a negative things about blackstab and how it's wounded people it's scarred people but it's you look at what happens to a person doing surgical intervention of a cancer like this and don't get me started.
So if a person does surgery and removes the melanoma that's fine you already did it you certainly want to treat it systemically even if you did the surgery.
If you can if you haven't done the surgery yet I'd suggest you find a practitioner that will help you do a topical attempt to a solution before you do the surgery that's just my opinion and I'm sticking to it.
All right so somebody asked you have a preferred topical treatment for basil cell carcinoma yes again so basil cell I would start with essential oils.
If that doesn't make it really go away within about two months if you're dabbing it on every day then I would go to the curcumin cream.
The curcumin cream again the only negative of the curcumin cream is that it stains.
So as long as you can it's in the spot where you can put mandate over it so it's not staining your pillowcases or buy some cheap pillowcases or something like that so you don't worry about it staining.
And you can keep the curcumin cream on this is worked just I think just what every time we've used it for basil cell at this point in time so that's been very encouraging it's just that negative of the staining.
Okay so we are going to unmute everybody and my voice is not that great because I have a cold I apologize so when I'll stick around for a couple questions here.
Yes Dr. Counties this is Cher.
Hello young lady.
Hi you know I have the little string of tumors like in the back of my neck shoulder whatever.
Would one of the creams be beneficial to me.
I do the frankincense but I didn't know if like the cure a med whatever.
So the cure a derm is spent for just topical.
So if you don't have it's not it's not a topical cancer it's not a skin cancer.
Now even these skin cancers like this they still have you know multicell epidermal lighting over the top of them so.
Typically when you put black salve on a melanoma it's not like you put the black salve on there and it starts eating away right away and you.
You know it increases your pain you know it's working typically you don't know what's working for sometimes a couple days.
Because it's got to eat through the first couple layers of skin.
Well that's one way that you'll see online how can I tell it looks like this it looks just like this is a melanoma or is it a mole.
Well you'll see online well put some black salve on there and you will know well I wouldn't necessarily recommend that but.
If you did put black salve on there like I had a mole when my wife was to eat her melanoma I have this mole and put black salve on it well a week later didn't do anything it didn't hurt nothing black salve I scraped it off and it didn't do anything because it was just a mole right now there are reports of a black salve help you the mole too but.
Usually it's going to be a melanoma that's going to eat away now if you have a deeper cancer so you have a cancer.
That's deeper than the layer of layers of epidermal tissue layers of your skin so it's underneath right deeper layer underneath your your fat layer that is right sub dermal.
There's no way any of these are going to get to it you can consider and we have done that with the curcumin cream we've added DMSO to it.
So DMSO is a driver and then you so you're adding a driver to it so that when you put it on it's going to drive it you know help help suck some of the curcumin through the skin and through the fat layer to the that's one way to get it through you can do that same thing with essential oils you could use a DMSO as the.
Carrier carrier oil yeah even though DMSO is like water.
It will still you can still use it as the carrier you can dab on some DMSO to you know it's like water but you're basically putting it on over a three inch round area let's say on the back of your neck and then putting you know five drops or two drops of frankincense and spirited it you won't get the birdie of the frankincense.
Because you have another liquid there.
And then the DMSO will help draw it in.
What is DMSO what is that?
DMSO is dimethyl sulfoxide which is just which is it can be used as an anti inflammatory itself.
That's what some people will use DMSO I have a bad need I'll put a little DMSO other D.
But we typically use it as a driver.
Because DMSO just like draws right through the skin.
Well my skin is very thin and very smooth where those are yeah so that'll make it easier to yeah I mean like there's no fat there's right.
But you do have a subcutaneous fat layer.
Yeah but you know that would be one thing to do you can buy we don't have just DMSO but you can buy it on Amazon.
And it comes in like an eight ounce bottle and you probably won't go through all that.
DMSO and you can dab it on it's just like water.
You can dab it on a cotton ball and then put it on the skin and then put a couple drops of the oil on it and one way to get it in.
If you use too much DMSO you will have the taste of garlic in your mouth.
I seem to get that anyways so something I'm and taking is causing that and I'm not sure what's causing that.
Well the only thing that would cause that would be a sulfur compound like garlic or eating onions.
Yeah but it hasn't been so much that I don't know I do that.
Curcumin or cucumber or something or another.
Curcumin wouldn't do it.
No I don't know.
Did I take you to MSM are you?
What is MSM?
MSM is it's an anti-inflammatory that a lot of people take.
Well you know what if you were taking it.
Yeah no.
No.
And certainly you could do a CBD oil over the top of the tomb.
Now we'll like by doing the DMSO and the frankincense will that try to kill it or will it try to draw it out?
Well DMSO is an anti-inflammatory so that could help decrease the inflammation right there.
But I would put something with it that could be a cancer killer like frankincense.
Yeah.
So that you're pulling the frankincense you're getting a double vanity there.
Yeah. Can I do that with the one of my armpit too?
Yeah.
Okay.
There you go.
Where do that?
I have a little bit of a different frankincense after I'm almost through with my young living one.
I have one from another company that I'm like, well let's just use that up.
Yeah, sure.
Absolutely.
Okay.
DMSO.
Yes.
Okay.
I'll order that.
Thank you.
Okay.
Question came in.
I had a noticeable increase in skin moles right before I was diagnosed with prostate cancer.
Is there any relationship between the two?
Probably not.
I don't know. Maybe if you search the research, you can find some correlation.
I can't think of one off the top of my head from a physiological standpoint.
That would make any sense to me right now.
Um.
You know, you know, maybe if your body was, you know, immune system was fighting the prostate cancer.
And that was starting to grow and get on a hand because obviously you had it before the diagnosis.
Um, so it happens in some of the patients whether you have an immune system.
It, uh, the cells on the, under, you know, face, but those are skin moles, you see, so I can't imagine any correlation.
All right.
Well, remember, if you have questions, this question here came from somebody who emailed it in.
So email those questions in.
And we'll get them answered the best we can.
And, um, we'll get this up on our Facebook page.
Thank you.
All right.
Bye.